pourquoi on vous a pas demandé à vous de
faire Harry Potter parce que franchement
les films de Chris Columbus sont
vraiment pas terribles quoi
qu'est-ce qui vous est arrivé
de me battre j'ai perdu contre un ours
contre nous et pas le mien en tout cas
[Rires]
la tondeuse de Jean-Jacques Annaud
Jean-Jacques
tondeuse hier
soir vous êtes le seul américain du
célébrissime groupe de comédiens
humoriste Monty Python vous avez renoncé
à la nationalité américaine désormais
vous êtes totalement britannique
pourquoi
je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
simplifie ma vie j'avais passé le plus
clair de mon temps en Angleterre et je
t'ai pas vraiment grand fan de bouche ou
de Rumsfeld donc je me suis dit que
l'heure était venu de mettre un terme à
tout ça stop fini finito passer à autre
chose et maintenant je suis British il
est bien le traducteur vous avez fini
finito alors voilà alors vous êtes né un
minerapolis vous avez 11 ans quand votre
père quitte le Minnesota pour la
Californie où il devient charpentier
dans un studio à Hollywood alors vous
d'abord vous êtes illustrateur pour un
certain nombre de magazines vous
travaillez aussi dans et en 1967 vous
installez à Londres ou deux ans plus
tard vous créez les Monty Python avec
Terry Jones Mike Palin Eric Idle John
kleeves et Graham Chapman les Monty
pixels qui ont inspiré ton respirez
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens ici
voilà alors le premier opus démenti
piton c'était de Monty piton Fline
Circus vous êtes scénariste parfois
acteurs en 1974 vous co-réalisez avec
Terry Jones Monty Python Sacré Graal un
monument quoi mindstone comme on dit en
français en 1976 vous réalisez seul
votre premier film Jabberwocky déjà très
inspiré de Lewis Carroll et c'est encore
le cas aujourd'hui dans le film qui vous
amène et puis vous écrivez la vie de
Brian vous réalisez bandit bandit et
puis c'est votre chef-d'oeuvre Brasil
donc la rencontre dites-vous de Franck
Capra et de Franz Kafka voilà Brasil est
un film ext extraordinaire déjà à
l'époque de Brasil gros problème avec
les majors compagnies avec les
producteurs vous avez tout le temps
beaucoup de problèmes
aux États-Unis c'était universel studio
qui avait ça et donc ils se sont dit que
c'était pas possible de le sortir qui
aurait pas de public c'était un film
minable et donc
ils ont mis un embargo sur le fil je
vais même pas passer mon film à des amis
aux États-Unis et donc le producteur
nous disait bon il faudra qu'on fasse
appel à des juristes qu'on se batte etc
mais en fait moi j'aurais dit non ils
ont des meilleurs juristes ils ont plus
de temps plus d'argent et donc je me
suis dit que il fallait que je mène une
bataille personnelle contre le directeur
du studio quelqu'un qui s'appelle
inshape et donc j'ai commencé à
apparaître en public j'étais dans l'un
des choses
et avec Bob denier et puis
je comprends que vous avez un problème
d'après ce que je comprends vous avez un
problème avec ce studio et moi j'ai dit
non moi j'ai fait un problème avec un
studio j'ai un problème avec un homme ce
type s'appelle shineberg et puis j'ai
sorti sa photo là j'ai montré sa photo à
tout le monde comme ça directement et
qu'on a mené cette bataille pendant un
certain temps et puis
le soir de la première de africain qui
était le grand film de Universal cette
année-là les critiques de Los Angeles
avant la sortie du film on voter que
c'était le meilleur film à plusieurs
égards et donc ils ont vu que c'était un
excellent et donc de dire que j'ai eu ma
revanche parce que évidemment Hollywood
ne m'a pas pardonné mais c'est l'un des
meilleurs moments de de ma vie en fait
il y a même eu carrément une publicité
qui est sortie un magazine professionnel
qui parlait d'argent de tout l'argent
qui était gagné ici ou là et moi j'ai
sorti une page entière où j'avais un
certificat de décès encadré de noir et
au milieu j'avais monsieur chineberg
quand allez-vous sortir mon film
précédent et puis j'ai signé et
apparemment personne n'avait jamais fait
de telle erreur dans le passé mais ça ou
de quelque chose d'aussi fou que ça a
marché c'est incroyable quand on sait
que donc Brasil les mecs ne voulaient
pas le sortir et que c'est uniquement
grâce à sa volonté et à son sens de la
provocation que ce chef-d'oeuvre qui est
Brasile a pu sortir vous êtes très
courageux c'est bien bravo
non non c'est pas du tout c'est pas une
histoire de courage c'est simplement de
croire en ce qu'on fait c'est tout et
c'est de se battre pour ce qu'on fait
c'est pas une question d'être courageux
d'avoir du courage j'avais pas le choix
vous savez alors après Brasil vous êtes
resté quatre ans sans rien réaliser
avant de revenir avec des aventures du
baron de Münchhausen quelques années
plus tard vous avez fait L'Armée des 12
singes avec Bruce Willis et Brad Pitt
Las Vegas Parano avec Johnny Depp et
Benicio Del Toro et en 2000 vous
commencez le film dont vous rêvez depuis
des années l'homme qui a tué Don
Quichotte avec Johnny Depp et Jean
Rochefort et malheureusement le tournage
est interrompu au bout d'une semaine
d'abord une tempête détruit le décor et
ensuite Rochefort a une hernie qui
l'empêche de monter sur un cheval donc
le film ne s'est pas fait
et on a eu Jean Rochefort ici qui est
venu pour la sortie du DVD
consacrée à l'échec du film parce que
même un échec ça fait quand même un DVD
intéressant voilà alors ensuite vous
avez fait des publicités vous étiez sans
doute un peu un peu déçu après cette
aventure des publicité pour Nike et en
2004 vous avez fait les frères Grimm
avec les frères Weinstein alors là
pareil vous avez encore des problèmes
avec Harvey Weinstein j'imagine non
[Applaudissements]
c'est intéressant c'était une
combinaison attirante en tout cas c'est
ce que ce que je peux vous dire vous
savez avec ces gens là vous avez envie
de rencontrer une seule fois dans votre
vie jamais plus tout simplement en fait
ils ont fait une erreur assez fatale
étant donné qu'il disposait d'argent il
pense que ils sont créatifs ils croient
qu'ils sont acteurs ils croient qu'ils
sont réalisateurs et en fait ils sont
rien de tout ça ce sont des vendeurs
c'est tout et donc les Weinstein font
leur boulot et si moi je fais mon boulot
eux font leur il y aura pas de problème
et tout ira bien et il est venu ici avec
[Rires]
la 28 ans c'est un homme heureux une
chose que je comprends pas terrible
c'est pourquoi on vous a pas demandé à
vous de faire Harry Potter parce que
franchement les films de Chris Columbus
sont vraiment pas terribles quoi trop
vieux pour le rôle moi pour moi
qui a écrit les Harry Potter et son
producteur voulait que je réalise le
premier film pourtant moi je savais
pertinemment que le studio voudrait pas
que ce soit moi parce que quelqu'un de
trop indépendant à leurs yeux il voulait
avoir quelqu'un de tout à fait sûr et
donc ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai été
à Los Angeles en première classe j'ai
ils m'ont payé le voyage et donc moi je
travaillais sur Don Quichotte pendant ce
temps là j'ai été invité à une réunion
qui était une réunion qui servait
absolument à rien ça je le savais
pertinemment d'avance et à Hollywood
comment dire en fait les gens à
Hollywood ont peur et si j'étais un peu
plus intelligent et bien j'aurais réussi
à les mettre à l'aise mais en fait ça
c'est pas vraiment quelque chose
d'amusant ce qui est beaucoup plus
amusant c'est de les rendre mal à l'aise
jusqu'à ça
alors vous revenez aujourd'hui avec un
film qui s'appelle tiedland qui sort le
28 juin alors le pitch c'est un peu
dites-vous la rencontre entre Alice au
pays des merveilles et psychose le film
d'Hitchcock c'est l'histoire d'un enfant
qui se construit comme elle peut malgré
une grande souffrance c'est une fable
sur la survie c'est l'histoire de
jay-zarose dont la mère meurt d'une
overdose et qui part s'installer dans
une vieille ferme avec son père joué par
Jeff Bridges qui était un rocker héroïne
Oman pour échapper à cette situation
elle s'évade dans dans l'imaginaire
voilà c'est un très beau film très
très particulier très très vénéneux
ce qu'on avait envoyé j'ai commencé à le
lire et au bout de cinq pages je me suis
dit attends c'est incroyable ce truc
c'est génial et donc
j'ai eu l'impression que ça ça nous
permet de voir comment pense un enfant
sans sentimentalisé les choses sans
romantisées les choses outre mesure et
donc ça permet tout simplement de mettre
l'enfant dans des situations étranges un
petit peu perturbantes et de voir
comment est-ce que cet enfant va
survivre et survivre grâce à son
innocence elle survie parce qu'elle
arrive à réinventer réimaginer refaire
le monde et pour moi c'était la première
fois que je lisais quelque chose
d'honnête sur les enfants vous êtes une
sorte de Lewis Carroll du 21e siècle
quelque chose d'amusant est-ce quelque
chose d'assez dérangeant aussi et ça ça
fait réfléchir les gens à la façon dont
ils voient le monde ça ça les oblige à
repenser le monde ça les oblige à voir
le monde avec l'innocence qui
caractérise les enfants avec le manque
de moralité de l'enfant et pour certains
croyez moi c'est vraiment une expérience
très dérangeante parce que avec l'âge on
a tendance à avoir de plus en plus peur
face à la vie les enfants n'ont pas peur
de la vie au contraire alors dans ce
film nous aborder deux sujets qui sont
tabous généralement par rapport à
l'enfance c'est-à-dire la drogue et la
nécrophilie c'est très dérangeant en
même temps
alors c'est vrai Thierry après
l'histoire de Don Quichotte qui a été
extrêmement dur pour vous bien entendu
50 préparation pour un film qui ne se
fait pas après votre expérience sur les
frères Grimm avec les frères Winston
vous dites finalement ce film ça vous a
redonné de l'enthousiasme pour faire du
cinéma vous dites finalement c'est
presque des vacances ce film quoi
parce que c'était pas un film un gros
budget il est pas besoin j'ai pas besoin
de toucher des millions de gens il
suffit que je cible une petite cible de
gens intelligents il y a pas d'effets
spéciaux pas de chevaux rien du tout
quatre acteurs c'est tout et donc je
dois dire que c'est vraiment
sympa de travailler avec des conditions
à minima
mesdames messieurs
1 2 3 4
en anglais
vous devez nous chanter Brasil oui je
sais vous détestez cette chanson
mais j'espère qu'il rentre pas en stop
parce que tu as devant chez nous
[Rires]
j'ai tout perdu
vous
êtes son idole alors i love you
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu